I'll give my acknowledgments a lot of
the following slides and some links to
news are given here given by dr. Phil
Barth professors John kumi Terry root
and Ken caldera so here is the
greenhouse gamble there are a small
chance of having very few ecological
impacts the predictions have gotten
harsher what does that mean that means
the first time that I checked out this
MIT policy groups wheel of misfortune as
they called it this is a nice way of
communicating probability wedges to a
lay audience right and what you can do
will do it in a second is you can click
on it the probability wedges are your
more often going to end up with
something that has a large probability
wedge than something that has a teeny
one when I started to get worried about
climate it must have been around
2006-2007 and found this this is what
the circle looked like of what we
expected for temperatures with no policy
changes guess where we are now so the
chances are very very slim that for what
we had most of this the chances are very
very slim that our temperature rise will
be this small so let me see if I can
find that in my web browser which I was
trying to have it up here and if it will
kindly allow me I may be signed in we
might be good yes there you go are we
going to win or lose we got off pretty
easy this time so it's an interesting
interactive tool and what this
particular pairing is showing is what's
happening with no policy or with the
policies that this particular center
studying policies at MIT advises so
that's kind of an interesting tool to
see why do we care why on earth then I
put this on full slide show this is a
brilliant graphic that shows why do I
care if I've gone up one degree C i live
in canada i live in minnesota and i
personally love it to be a little bit
warmer right but the answer is no this
is this is a graphical representation of
what came out of the IPCC 2000s
seven report Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change many many climate
scientists working together and already
you get this kind of things we have
decreasing water availability increasing
drought increasing wildfire risk does
any of this sound kind of familiar and
then the black are the ones that really
caught my attention greater risk of
extinction I mean and this was a group
of scientists deliberately trying not to
be alarmist so greater risk for twenty
to thirty percent of known species by
the time you get up here around five
degrees C which it looks very likely we
may get to they're not saying greater is
they're saying extinction of you know
nearly half known species it's that kind
of thing that keeps me working on this
though this is pretty much the volunteer
job you know it's just it's important
and I got to say it's a wonderful thing
to work on something that you personally
think is that important I don't know it
adds a certain kind of joy even though
it's a kind of grim topic this is just
kind of the mechanism of why is it
getting warmer basically we changed the
atmosphere the composition of the
atmosphere and it equilibrate SAT a
slightly different temperature than what
we've historically had this other
graphic which we're going to power
through because I realize I am
luxuriously taking my time but we've got
a lot of slides is what are really these
sources of and so when I post these
slides two hours a class set you will
see all these nice links so what's our
temperature like what's really warming
the world and then you can page down and
see is it Earth's orbit all the things
that people say it can't possibly be
greenhouse gases right and as you go
down is it volcanoes is it all of these
combined it's like no and you finally
get down to deforestation ozone aerosols
greenhouse gases those other things
actually reduce temperature bit
greenhouse gases are a bit more than
that and when you add all of that
together you get a pretty darn good fit
to the model so there's a number of
things that are showing that
pretty incontrovertible you know as
opposed to when I first started teaching
this when there were a lot of people
arguing about this the it seems that
more and more understand no this is a
real problem so what are we going to do
about this is really the question and
this is from John's John kameez book dr.
John kameez book this really is a pretty
brilliant book that I strongly recommend
and his thought is think about what if
we say it's that assume the solution
thing assume we have to not exceed the
two degrees C limit you saw there's
still some pretty dire problems at two
degrees C right that's still pretty
we're still having a greater risk of
extinction for a lot of species and a
lot of a host of other problems many of
which we're seeing today but it's better
than if it gets worse what do we do and
his you know he's presenting co2 data
that you can get from oh eight hundred
thousand years ago to now and see that
we are running a rather unintended
experiment on our own atmosphere and you
know what happens what happens in the no
policy case if we're doing greenhouse
gas concentrations you can you can read
this in the book you can you can keep
looking at this I but you can see that
every time that people are saying well
if we put in a policy to do this what
would happen it turns out that we tend
to exceed that goal so far we've been
exceeding it it's because there really
isn't the political and cultural will to
take this on and do it and so the latest
IPCC the fifth assessment report is out
you can read it and you can see you know
co2 continues to go up Arctic summer sea
ice goes down you know temperatures are
going up in the ocean sea level is
rising that's what you would think the
the thing that this report gets critique
for more often than anything else is
that it's too conservative again
scientists are trying very hard to not
be seen as alarmists they really want to
be sure of their facts before they're
talking about this and sometimes it
makes it sound you know to to somebody
who's
trouble in their current life oh wow
they're not sure well mmm so it's a it's
actually a little bit of a problem here
is a scarily pression ad from nineteen
sixty-two one of the old oil companies
talked about and they were proud of this
of course because one of the big fears
back then was that we were going to
slide into another killing Ice Age this
actually was one of the fears back in
the 60s each day we supply enough energy
to melt seven million tons of glacier
Wow and they were probably right Wow and
so there's a number of links that you
can dig out if you're looking at the
slide set after I posted on coursework
of just there's a lot of confusion but
there's a lot more even in the confusing
you know really good science here you
know now the oceans are up taking more
co2 again that would be good news until
suddenly they're not right I mean that's
one of the larger understood things is
how much of a sink do we have here is it
a two thousand year turn over 5,000 year
turn over what will happen but you can
you can follow these links yourself and
see what you think sea level will rise
by one meter it's unavoidable all of
these links that i'm going to show you
in the next few slides that are in this
sort of formatter just over the last
couple months I mean the news has
exploded in this area arctic sea ice sea
ice loss likely to be reversible whoa if
the earth gets cooler so that's very
good news if we could cool the planet we
could get the ice back why do I harp on
ice I'll get into this more in a bit but
as summer Arctic ice disappears we are
losing our ability to reflect the
incoming summer sunlight and back when I
got concerned in 2006 and thought what
would I work on to help the situation
people were talking about that one
effect was responsible for about twenty
percent of global temperature rise
overall now the latest that I've heard
from hanging with the climate scientists
at the agu meetings is it's more like a
third so more like thirty thirty three
percent of global temperature
comes from the fact we don't have much
reflective ice anymore so that would be
very good news for continuing to cool
the planet a bit instead of have this
runaway as we're having now and why do
we care well again it's more and more in
the news especially this last year or
two how very much it costs coastal
cities per year to try to shore up
against rising seas by doing simple
things like building levees or make sure
that their septic there you know
outfalls come out above water level
somewhere it's and you know I've been
advised there's more and more data you
know more and more estimates because
people are actually building it there's
good old New York City a two billion
dollars a year and there's lots of other
data points but I've been told don't put
too many there but it isn't because they
aren't there and of course graphic
artists have a good time communicating
this this hasn't happened yet but it's
the sort of thing that concerns people
and right now the cost is billions per
year per city to deal with these very
fundamental issues after 2050 the
projections are as more and more ice has
melted and sea level rise comes you know
becomes more and more rapid trillions of
dollars so it's one of those expenses
that you would be so much better off
doing some prevention rather than trying
to cure after you of course ruined a lot
of people's lives more you know fun from
the graphic artists but boy it paints a
picture doesn't it this is a scuba diver
in the New York subway system it's a you
know it makes you think and then there's
all kinds of you know fossil fuels news
again over the last couple months that
oil advertisement I showed you burning
all the fossil fuels could melt our
Antarctica entirely it's an interesting
headline flash credit scheme backfired
apparently some rather phony fictitious
exchanges being done on you know how you
can do it get a carbon credit for things
but this one was phony and the
greenhouse gas emissions were actually
more Elon Musk talking fossil fuels yes
and the Sun Edison solar farm
eating gasp eating natural gas so
there's good news you know part of the
joy of seeing this more and more in the
press in a more and more balanced way is
there's more attention and there's more
good news to point to this is a
fascinating one that we don't have time
to delve into but it's showing how all
over the United States how our energy is
generated where we are that is a very
fascinating chart which you might want
to check out this is a scary one if we
continue to burn fossil fuels of course
we have more and more co2 and they're
warning this particular group of
scientists is warning that there is no
co2 technol fix even with even with the
co2 that we have already in the oceans
and in the atmosphere we are we've
acidified the oceans and warmed them
considerably to an extent that it would
take a very very long time to recover
even now if we stop now that is the
stuff that could certainly paralyze you
if you dwelled on that but again let's
try to think our way through solutions
it means we have to change our ways
pretty quickly and how we're going to do
that I don't know there's there some
people who have great hopes for the
meetings later this year in Paris we'll
see the jet stream has become
destabilized because again climate
scientists tell me this because we don't
have the steady driving force that we
had historically a very very cold up
there at the North Pole compared to the
rest of the world so you can imagine
that you have a less of a delta between
those two regions and you've
historically had this nice stable jet
stream through most of human history and
what you have now is less of a driving
force less of a differential so if
there's any perturbation whatsoever you
start having the jet stream change its
configuration and that means that you
get unusual weather patterns that we
haven't had before like what's happening
in California right now and then that
part must be in our timer or something
from an old slide set and then it will
suddenly change to the other
configurations
suddenly then you might get really heavy
rains it's over the course of human
civilization again what I've heard at
the age of you is that over you know the
last 10,000 years or so we've had an
extraordinarily stable and of a couple
of steady Jetstream configurations where
where we could count on basically where
are we going to live where are we going
to plant our crops and we don't have
that anymore and you can see we're
getting more and more severe storms with
horrible human costs it's it's not good
and then we've got you know it's getting
hard to deny these hottest summers
coldest winters that are happening for
most of the Pacific Northwest again go
on the site and follow these links if
you want heat and drought you know
cooking fish alive a million and a half
fish of one species up in the Pacific
Northwest and people getting desperate
enough to put big plastic black plastic
balls on their reservoirs to reduce
evaporative loss now that sounds kind of
interesting but I will tell you that
this this particular piece of news is
actually good news for me so so stay
tuned and then climate change in
politics this is actually a hopeful read
this top one the year humans got serious
about climate change right because
that's what it takes before we can get
somewhere and then various you know
political figures saying things they
should or shouldn't or denying this or
that but Obama making an urgent appeal
he went to Alaska making an urgent
appeal for climate change action right
how that some of the dynamics of how
people reinforce each other's opinions
that there's no problem is really
fascinating how to get people to care
Jason box one of the heroes of climate
change really he was one of the guys who
put all the cameras or many of the
cameras out in distant distant cold
places to film the disappearance of ice
for that really impactful movie chasing
ice which if you haven't seen it do just
a great climatologist has basically
gotten so despairing about the
atmosphere of denial in the US he has
moved his family with his 33 year old
daughter in his wife to
denmark where he thinks maybe they've
got the best chance of surviving the
climate onslaught I mean this is a guy
who was tacking plastic sheets on
Greenland trying to see if that would
slow them out this is a passionate
dedicated expert guy and he's you know
from from the interview that i was
reading in the huffington post this that
this will point you to or i guess this
is the one that is related to it you
know that's a he's just given up and
that's scary but we don't have to but
before we go to the hope let me share
with you a little more bad news
professor terry route was married to
what is the widow of professor stephen
schneider who was one of the really
outspoken proponents of letting people
know about climate change and what's
happening and why it's a problem and she
is she was one of the early encouragers
of my own particular work she and steve
both of them and she is hmm she's an
expert on the pressures of climate
change on species why does it hurt your
your species if it gets a little bit
warmer here and so she will do a much
more eloquent job than I can here so
look up her video but she talks about
basically how the species interact you
can imagine if you the predator for this
particular species that species run you
know has moved away someplace where you
can't adapt to your food has gone you
have to go another direction because
you're tolerating the cold or the heat
differently it things just start really
getting in a bad way for species to
survive it's part of why we're in the
sixth wave of extinction why we are
going rapidly off this cliff and this is
a beautiful little tale of introducing
or killing off wolves coyotes red fox
now you're reintroducing them and it
should all work right because you know
who eats who who's preying on who and
it's such a colossal mess when humans
interfere without all the facts so one
of the keys that I take away from all of
this is actually Steve Schneider I used
to say this is that you do not you do
not do something that wouldn't make
sense just because you're desperate you
make sure that you know if I'm going to
stop burning this or I'm going to make
this particular source or that it has to
actually make some rational sense you
know there if you just say oh there's
too many wolves let's introduce coyotes
and see what happens oh you've actually
got to figure it out first it tends to
be more complex than you think and so
the types of adaptation that species do
are they're shifting their ranges to
either go you know up up or down towards
a pole where it's colder or go up in
elevation and as I say things have
things change my great at different
rates for instance plants aren't going
to migrate nearly as quickly as animals
that might be used to feeding on them do
and so you're ending up with you know
this this thing where one species is
going in this direction another in that
and you're just ending up with a mess
everybody's starving you've suddenly run
into a new predator you you have no food
things are blooming at the wrong time
and so right now the background
extinction rate has been less than one
species in a thousand over a thousand
years our current extinction rate is
about one in ten over a thousand years
so less than one in a thousand to one in
10 which is alarming and so going back
to that thermometer that rising
thermometer of doom that I showed if
we're up 3.6 degrees Fahrenheit
expecting four hundred thousand species
extinctions up 7.2 which is not
inconceivable a million species
extinction so this is you know this is
alarming this is our web of life so what
are we going to do you know here's
calvin and hobbes thinking about giving
up right i think it's big enough you
guys can all read it
so is that an option leaving actually
more and more in the news it is right
people are saying okay we're gonna go
colonize this okay that sounds like a
long-term plan so here's our challenges
you know you guys if you like challenges
you've got a lifetime of work ethic
which is magnificent if you happen to
like challenges so some insights from
cold cash cool climate you know our
choices for response to climate change
or mitigation adaptation and suffering
climate problems big urgent
misunderstood and therefore fertile
ground for starting new ventures and
then I love what his his focus is this
is why I love this book rather than one
simplified response rather than assuming
that we're going to come to the
political chord that anytime soon that's
going to unify the planet and go in the
right direction entrepreneurs knowing
what they're doing knowing what the site
is like the founders of Tesla you know
let's get us off fossil fuels and have
electric cars as an option I mean that
was really their vision when they
founded that try things fail fast do all
the things entrepreneurs do and that can
make an enormous impact you know you
might be trying over in water
conservation you might be trying more
efficient farming you might be trying in
different kind of power and together can
actually make an impact while whatever
political process is going on goes on
which may be too slow he also says the
forecast you know as you say well we're
doomed underestimate this particular
factor the factor of the entrepreneur
the factor that you can have people of
independent thought and creativity going
along and you know making an impact and
so that too should give you a little bit
of hope and so here he is assuming the
solution okay we're not going to exceed
2 degrees c how do we get there I mean
that's the next step right once you know
you can do this you know you can do this
okay how much can we keep emitting
what's our what's our limit you define
the pathways you assess what's possible
and you try various options but you try
them sanely let's not introduce wolves
and coyotes and watch and see whether
that worked you know try things in a way
that's
going to have a negative impact the
other thing we're fighting is that most
of our infrastructure has been has been
built you know right now is pretty aging
and most of the 2050 infrastructure so
the stuff we're going to have 35 years
from now is going to be built between
now and then right it's not like we're
going to have stuff from the 1800s doing
that so as we look at this green
building for instance which we have a
talk on I mean that's really important
that we are we have a chance to build
things now that are going to be what are
affecting our future in 2050 right we
can do it right now so do it now right
waiting just costs more we turn our
billions per year into trillions let's
let's make sure that we're looking at
the same things start small think big
get going I totally agree with that of
course your other option is just doing
nothing which in some sense feels like
what much of the world's been doing
right and then you know what all these
impacts are right you've seen him and
we're living a lot of this right higher
temperatures fires you know it's
droughts so what are the options here so
rather than do nothing we can we can try
to cure it at the source we can change
our energy mix we can adapt to rising
sea levels we can invent new energy
sources a lot of people look at
geoengineering and geoengineering is a
fascinating combination of things that
at least to my mind some make a lot of
sense and I'm really worried me and you
can see over here a collection of you
know the guy who proposed trillions of
orbiting solar lenses okay if you can
fend off incoming sunlight way way out
there it will keep things cooler but you
know how do you undo that if you decide
that's wrong how about if you decide you
wish you could grow food here again but
it's shaded you know I they're just
things there that worry me a little bit
right and and you can go through these
options and see what I mean it's
wonderful to come up with these ideas I
think for an exercise we should come up
with some ideas as well but we really
have to think I'm through before we risk
a lot
so some look interesting some have
really risky impacts and the ones that
really worried me are the ones that can
go worldwide very quickly some people
look at that as a real feature i I don't
I think it would be nice to do things on
a local scale that you could undo you
could reverse if you decided something
was wrong because Humanity is very good
and not quite realizing all the
unintended consequences so if you do
things in a way that you could undo them
that seems to me extremely prudent
geoengineering involves these very
complex issues some of the complex
issues are the moral hazard which is
that if I assume that some genius over
there is going to be able to fix it all
then I can keep on driving a 10 mile per
gallon gas hog you know as far as I want
and I you know I can live a very co2
producing lifestyle and know that my
kids don't have to worry because
somebody else is going to fix it because
geoengineering is going to work and that
really is a hazardous mindset here's the
Earth's energy balance and some of these
are what you know what what people are
thinking about changing so anybody who's
talking about reflecting things from the
surface so the ice that's disappeared
doesn't get to reflect as much some are
talking about reflecting from changing
where clouds are or having more clouds I
think you would mess with the water
cycle at your peril and besides which
there's an awful lot of heat exchange
that happens here and here's our whole
you know greenhouse gas effect of what
what are our radiation zandri radiations
as we change the composition of our
atmosphere staring at things like this
you know with how much energy is coming
in and going out on average from these
very roots various routes I find very
intriguing and thought-provoking so
there's two distinct strategies right
there's the carbon dioxide removal and
there's the solar radiation management
which can be on the ground can be
altering the atmosphere can be launching
mirrors parking things that you know
orbital points to check I mean there
there are many things that have been
proposed
and people from 2009 you know have been
just documenting some of the interesting
ideas out there and it's fascinating
reading one thing that got a lot of
attention was Mount Pinatubo was
volcanoes because it turns out that if
you have aerosols if you have
particulates if you have what volcanoes
emit you actually have cooling for a
couple years afterwards and that's kind
of interesting and people have even
observed that as we cleaned up the
pollution that was much more in my
childhood than it is now of the sulfates
that were around we actually it looks
like a little bit of our temperature
spike came from making it cleaner
because sulfates are actually very good
at keeping things a little bit cooler
just like co2 and methane keep it warmer
sulfates keep it cooler so the thought
is well let's let's do this and so I've
been in workshops where people are
seriously discussing this as like the
main option and it's tempting because
you can see that it's the sort of thing
that could work you just need some
aircraft there you know we're capable of
putting it up there or float a balloon
you can for not so much money have a
very worldwide impact people like me
worry a lot about you can have a
worldwide impact and you know the exit
plan is not you can't just round up all
those molecules right you have to wait
for them to precipitate out of the air
and people are studying it very very
carefully to try to make sure we don't
do something really silly so Kenny
caldera has been looking at this for
years and I really appreciate how he's
trying to study this thoroughly so that
when and if our backs are to the wall
will know what the risks are before
somebody goes off and does this and what
many people mean by geoengineering when
they say geoengineering is this
particular solution is well what about
you know stratospheric sulfates and so
for him turning on geoengineering has
big effects very soon well that's a
that's a positive feature that's a good
thing but turning it back off I find
this very right
you returned very quickly your
temperature comes very close to what
this is what it originally would have
been it pops up there very quickly
quicker than it's doing now putting even
more pressure on species so this to me
is a is a very undesirable feature of
having something that once you're doing
it you've kind of got to keep on doing
it or you're you know even if you find
there's some unintended consequence or
you find that you know you're kind of in
more sudden transitions than you were so
thankfully people are looking carefully
at that there's a host of other things
we could say about this but I just
wanted to give an intro about this you
know many many studies have been done
one that I really like of a
geoengineering is by another fellow from
this area dr. Armand new kerman's and he
like I has an HP background but he he is
working on something that John Latham
proposed originally and that is to try
to put clouds where you want them to
reflect so instead of reflecting way up
in the atmosphere or reflecting at the
surface or with the ice he wants to have
clouds at a kind of intermediate area
and have these reflect sunlight a lot
and what I really love about this is
when you stop you stop you know that
there's no residual problem and what
you're doing is you're making clouds
which are pretty you know ubiquitous and
putting them where you want them to so I
find this a fascinating one it's in my
mind one of the good guys but what I
would say is as you are looking at what
you want to do in this world of helping
the planet I mean this really is the
image right I got this off a greeting
card which I've tried hard to give
credit to but it's a fragile thing and
really carefully what will you carefully
try so here we now get into what I've
been working on so i looked at the ice
albedo feedback effect I think I'll run
that movie our short video of doom again
and anybody who wasn't here at the
beginning could get to
have the joy of trying to guess what on
earth are looking at i think we've given
you enough hints though so what you're
looking at up here it'll hopefully keep
looping through is you've got month and
year up here we're counting through from
late nineteen seventy-nine through 2012
and we're looking down at the North Pole
and we're seeing bright reflective ice
which is the white basically what we're
really looking at is the age of sea ice
this is what these researchers were
doing was looking at the age it happens
that the older Isis the brighter it is
don't worry we will cycle through again
if you don't touch it all and what we're
finding is that every winter you know
ice does grow back but young ice is
almost as dark as open ocean and
therefore not very good at reflecting
sunlight and so you'll see that over
time you know you get into the 90s we're
getting less and less of this bright
reflective ice back to orient yourself
here's Alaska Siberia Canada Greenland
and we're losing an awful lot of ice out
the Fram Strait and more and more of
these black and red dots are appearing
what on earth are they they're all the
buoys that scientists were putting out
there to try to figure out what's
happening to the ice what so you see
more and more data gathering happening
here over time so here's the last time
through I promise you can just see this
this phenomenal shrinkage we're down to
twenty five percent of the volume and
fifty percent of the area we used to
have back just a few decades ago I think
is the right way maybe I have those flip
but at any rate it's it's a profound
change in just three decades of how much
ice we have lost yes how does tiny
change how reflective the ice oh oh
thank you yes excellent question when
you have a first-year ice you get that
sort of glare ice that so I promised
that I would stop but if I'm answering
this will let it keep running oh you
have that glare ice that you found on a
road maybe or ice like you have in a
hockey rink it is it has it's very
perfect and that's what happens
initially you get a very perfect layer
as it goes through freeze-thaw cycles
over years you build up
imperfections you build up air pockets
water pockets you know junk and it turns
out it gets brighter and brighter over
time and that's what we've lost and so
you know what on earth do we do about
that it's hard to see it rebooting
itself unless we make the world
substantially colder place somehow so
that's that's a very interesting this
was put together by researchers ignatius
rigor and John Wallace up at University
of Washington and its really pretty key
info um back to the slideshow which has
disappeared come here from current slide
so what's happening now as we're melting
ice is that more and more as it melts
what we have more opening ocean area we
have increased open ocean temperature we
have an increased absorption of solar
energy so it's this positive feedback
loop and any engineer in the room I'm
sure positive feedback loop makes you go
wow is it in the right direction well I
know it's not Oh and so this was back
when i made this slide many many years
ago you know this was estimated to be
about twenty percent of global
temperature rise now it's estimated to
be more like a third and this was the
IPCC that report that I showed you some
information from early on this was their
prediction for I smelled so all of their
prediction is all this blue well what
happened oh I know what happened there
and this red was their prediction the
red was the average of their predictions
from oh I guess around 1952 a while from
now and the change from the nineteen
seventy nine to nineteen ninety you know
that was their baseline what's the
change bin and so we're down to this is
come on this is down to area of ice and
we're down to about fifty percent I'm
sorry for the jog there I had resized it
to let's my my blue line show up of all
things and that meant that this added
thing that I put in for the 2007 to 2012
data just has gotten displaced because I
didn't realize I had messed up that
formatting but way way worse than the
word
than the most pessimistic predictions
that the IPCC was making back as they
were getting that that particular
assessment put together so it's bad news
this is part of what people say about
some of the projections that we're
trying to work from are actually not mmm
not concerned enough not well they're
concerned but not not pessimistic enough
people are really trying to be
deliberately conservative as they State
this so that they're not alarming people
needlessly oh that's interesting I
didn't change the title either my
apologies I just added this one today
this is about my work of I got an
article written last year in Fast
Company about my attempts to slow down
the melt of the Arctic ice and so just a
post set in our readings too so what on
earth am i doing because this is
something also i want to share with you
so you can see where i'm coming from and
see as you're thinking wow I've got a
great idea for you fill in the blank
this is one person's journey not
particularly sophisticated in climate or
business or politics to start with but
it's been a very interesting education
yes very much an engineer and so you
know it's one person's journey and
hopefully it's illustrative and
interesting I've been lucky enough i
conferred with climate scientists from
the beginning because I sure didn't want
to go astray I'm very keenly aware I'm
an engineer not a climate scientist but
get beautiful quotes like this that this
is you know grabs one of the most
important things half dozen or so most
important things that might have in
effect and that kind of thing keeps you
working those unpaid volunteers because
it matters here's a couple of things
harvested out of that video that I was
showing you so june nineteen eighty
compared to june 2002 compared to jun
2012 there isn't much multi-year ice
left here and so what are we doing quite
simply put we're trying to figure out
the right materials to reflect sunlight
so take the place of the disappearing
ice use the skill set I happen to have
and say oh that's a material
problem and try to figure out what
material would not be harmful to put
there and it looks like it's applicable
to you know all kinds of areas and I've
been cooking this up since you know as I
said at the beginning of this talk you
know since feeling like a Mack truck was
about to flatten me and I was standing
between the little kid with the teddy
bear so what do you do while you choose
something that's going to be quite
harmless and you choose something
inexpensive enough and you do it in a
way that you could undo it if you had to
because they'll always be some
unintended consequence how bad will it
be and should you undo it and so my
ground rules for a solution are
basically first the doctor right first
do no harm and make sure it's fast
enough to do some good I am perfectly
aware that this is not the long-term
solution for instance the long-term
solution is getting the right energy mix
the right conservation solutions but
what I was concerned by is the decades
it's going to take us to get there and
so the thought is this is a band-aid
this is a bandaid that should be able to
be used to get us there to give us a
little more breathing room to get there
that's its sole purpose because if we
keep on heating up anything we put out
there is going to eventually you know
not not do enough to solve this
particular problem but let's make it
fast enough to do some good now
sustainable ecologically respectful
reversible right the first do no harm
and it seems to me if you can do
something and undo it you get to be in
the delightful place that engineers like
to be so here we are with temperature or
co2 on this axis you know an
uncontrolled situation and here we are
maybe we over correct things and we are
in the next ice age you know the deadly
ice age that humble oil was so happy
that they were averting that's
overcorrected right how do we get out of
that if we do things that we could keep
tweaking so that the argument is about
how I wish we went back to the 1970s
instead the 1980s man I would be one
happy woman so you know you want to make
it so you can tweak it where you want to
be and so we've had many adventures over
the years we've been doing testing from
our deck here in sunny Bay
riya to testing up on a lake up in the
Sierra Nevada mountains for a few years
working on instrumentation Satish Shetty
has been with me from year to so just a
year into it joined in to do
instrumentation for us and we've just
been blasting away Minnesota has been
one of our very best test sites this in
the backyard of a retired PhD chemist
who is really handy with his workshop
and really generous with this time and
we've put all kinds of tests areas there
and there's one of sati shins newer
buoys and we've gotten really good data
sets there so there's there's the pond
owner and his buddy and sucky should me
again of course advertising Cal forgive
me and at that point when I put that
together you know six years of lab and
field testing and we just keep looking
at what's the performance of these high
albedo materials last year we got a
really really nice set you know we took
what had been sorting out to be the best
materials over the past over the
previous few years and put them over
wide areas of this pond with good
segmentation in it so that we could see
that it was delaying the best materials
were delaying the melt by several days
that may not sound like much but in a
small pond that that's indicative of
doing really well and in large you know
in the arctic itself ice experts that
I've been conferring with four years
assure me that just a delay of a few
weeks or an earlier start of a few weeks
to keep the ice around a little bit
longer could do a lot to slow down this
you know seemingly inevitable feedback
loop maybe we can start rebooting it we
even tested up in Barrow Alaska last
year which was a real a real adventure
and the logistics are so tough that
we're not sure that we have a usable
data set out of it yet but we've been
through the experience of being a place
where the GPS coordinates are not
actually accurate for where the lakes
are where the Wi-Fi is really difficult
to get your data out you know just a lot
of learning about when you are on the
very frontier Pharaoh Alaska is way up
there when you're on the very frontier
things that you take for granted are a
little more difficult and here are the
stars of where we tested we did once in
Canada we
a couple spots here in California
Minnesota Barrow and my brothers trying
to talk me into testing in Maine which I
think would be a really good idea so
that's that's kind of where we have done
testing to date it's been fueled by the
fact that this is powered on donations
and so though we are longing to test in
Greenland for instance that's just too
expensive and so at this point not a
feasible option what we're doing because
we're fueled on donations because it's
kind of a non-profit mission to try to
save the world's polar ice there doesn't
seem to be a profitable company out of
that yet is to finally allow myself to
become distracted by going the indirect
route of trying to conserve water we've
got a drought it's getting our attention
and our techniques are very good at
cooling water and reducing evaporation
so why don't we try to do something
about that and so that's what we have
just started to seriously back up and
formalize that data and go after some
funding to try to demonstrate that I
mean you all know well unless you've
just recently come to California we've
had a horrific drought for four years
and we really need we really need to do
something about it and the same
techniques we're using to try to slow
down I smelt actually would be terrific
for this so we've been lucky enough
actually to bring somebody new into the
team who's who's pictured there and
sitting in this class to take a really
good data set for some of our materials
out in a sunny parking lot nearby and to
really formalize this enough to have
gone to a good water meeting last week
by sustainable Silicon Valley and start
connecting with the NASA and state
officials and you know state water
officials to start figuring out how
we're going to get funded to get this
out on a reservoir and as I said at the
beginning you know my my little preview
don't do that to me of saying that these
guys who are putting black plastic balls
out on their reservoir are actually some
of the best news I've seen in a long
time for us somebody was paying them
do that I'm sure or at least gave them
permission and this costs a lot and we
cost our materials that we've been using
that we find perform really well about
170th of the cost of this about one and
a half percent and our methods keep
water cooler whereas black plastic balls
I don't have their temperature data but
I would be quite positive I'd be willing
to bet many beers that they're heating
their water and therefore harder on
wildlife so we're finding that to be an
exciting approach and that may generate
us enough income from that to start
actually moving on in a more
far-reaching way to try to save the
polar ice which is a very essential
lever in climate change that you know
the idea of doing this rather than
building a reservoir or a reverse
osmosis plan it's just you can do it
quickly you can undo it if you need to
you know you can move it to the next
drought stricken place if we're in an El
Nino year you know it's it's got some
big advantages so thanks and who has
quite great oh so awkward we're testing
on my foot ponds and Alaska what
materials exactly room using yes and do
they pose right to go there and pick
them back up so I like to think about
this being on I didn't get a just a
regular cup or anything I like to think
of the backpackers ethos right if you
don't want to leave food around you
don't want it one of my favorite types
of materials and the one that we've been
working on for a long time our variance
of floating sand hollow glass spheres
because you don't really want I think to
put a lot of organic there you might
need to put a little bit there as a
binder but sand you can hardly get more
harmless than that sio2 I mean it's
everywhere and you can get various forms
of hollow you can pass this around of
hollow glass spheres or these are
particularly spheres these are a larger
version that are reflective so they're
they're relatively high albedo there's
certainly higher albedo than
an ocean that float and what we find in
that Minnesota pond is that as it has a
really attractive feature as we go
through freeze-thaw cycles which you do
in the spring so you can see the various
materials that were there and this was
the best one as you go through those
various freeze-thaw cycles the hollow
glass spheres tend to come to the top
which is exactly where they're needed
we've tried a number of other types of
materials the most miserable winter of
my life was putting sheets around I can
really understand one of the reasons why
if Jason box thought that that was the
best thing that you could possibly do
for saving ice and you know there he was
on the Discovery Channel nailing these
sheets into Greenland well with my
smaller experiences on the lake up in
the California Sierra Nevada mountains
and then over there in over there in
Minnesota I mean it's it's horrific when
you're putting these big masses of
sheets surrounding your instrumentation
buoy going back up there you know in
your spare time to see how it's doing
and find it's always shifted there is no
way to effectively anchor it which tells
you that you know surely eventually you
could solve that problem too but it's
going to cost a lot and so I'm very very
fond of these particular types of
materials these hollow glass appears
they they behave pretty darn well so
that's that's the play and they're used
in everything you know they're used in
building materials to make things
they're used in lots of materials to
make them lighter and to make them less
thermally conductive for good heat
insulation so you can find all kinds of
them well they can fall apart the ones
i'm passing around is actually a variant
on that it's not strictly spheres it's a
consumer post-consumer recycled glass
where it's been composited by this one
company and so it floats not from a
hollow gas core which is what hollow
glass spheres will do
the formal hollow glass spheres which
can be pretty indestructible I mean you
could drive a truck over those but these
these will keep abrading against each
other and eventually you open up those
those pores and then they will say and
you know you can choose ones
intentionally that will sink over time
if you're concerned about having it
float forever I mean there's all kinds
of things that you can do to help
minimize your environmental impact on it
the first thing that we really wanted to
know is do we have something that slows
down and then that looks economical and
yeah you think we do so there's a lot of
testing left to be done any any other
questions yes oh so you uh let's say
leidos trophy glacier itself or the
ocean will it have any impact underneath
the sort of life lay your else you know
I used to show a slide that I've
realized as I try to pack more and more
intro stuff into this I get this shorter
and shorter but one slide that I put in
that I really take very seriously is
this beautiful graphic somebody put out
years ago of the undersea life even in
the Arctic I mean it is a rich ecosystem
under there and so one of the things
that I think is very important is to not
I mean this is not how I would actually
want to do it I do not want to carpet
the whole thing that this looks so
regular because tony is he put this
stuff out you know had these five foot
on a side well we're reusing the frames
and spread them in there so it looks
like a carpet but it's actually all
these individual wells but what I would
like to see our areas that are covered
in areas that are not because I think
that's important and I think it's
important that if you have things as
close as you can get to a mono layer
you're also going to have even in the
middle of your densely covered area
you're going to have areas where
sunlight can get through to because it
would yeah it would not be doing you a
favor to just suffocate at all it would
be almost as bad as the orbiting solar
mirrors right but you'd be doing it more
locally on your ocean surface did no I
saw somebody holding it up to light any
other questions
these are good questions yes can you
talk more about the policy and
challenges related to actually
implementing the solution if you find
out that it really is very effective
what I knew the answer to that boy so
what we've right and that's part of you
know part of what you get here is
somebody who honestly is trying to
figure her way through this and who is
an engineer not a politician hmm i think
our first step and i really think it's a
good one is to prove this out on water
and to try to help this i think is going
to be a very good step towards gaining
acceptance for these materials there's a
great deal of water quality testing we
should do those of you who are materials
gurus or materials literate no and MSDS
right material safety data sheet goes
with every chemical every compound and
the MSDS is for what we're using comes
up very very clean and we had no trouble
getting permission to use our types of
materials on that Lake up in the Sierra
Nevada mountains that was actually
people's drinking water and they never
had an issue I mean it was from their
water district that gave us their
permission so the materials are good but
too from that standpoint as far as we
know so far but to be able to prove
those out on a fair-sized region and
have people see that and see it cooling
things and saving water I think would be
a big step up for us that that's one of
the really important steps we have had
so so part of what I didn't tell the
story here that I guess I could a tax
lawyer included more was that we've been
through a couple business accelerators
the cleantech open sustainable Silicon
Valley and made a lot of connections
there and we've had a number of really
nice conversations with people at NASA
who have had a sustainability effort
which really seems aimed at helping to
leverage people like us with all that
amazing infrastructure that they have
right and so the hope is that at some
point we will be able to collaborate
with somebody like that who could
perhaps monitor our our tests as sort of
a fair broker you know as an impartial
judge it's a I've been very excited our
water speaker who's coming in a couple
of weeks was a second-level referral for
us from Felicia Marcus I mean it's time
now for me to reach out to people like
Felicia Marcus and I've done so who is
she she's the head of the California
Water Resources Board and she's been
giving talks to the MIT club and act era
and the Dartmouth alumni group and just
she is wow she is really great she's a
policy maker she is the head of the
Water Resources Board but she's very
technically comfortable and very
brilliant woman and so people like that
you know trying to make connections like
that but I don't know a magic bullet the
puzzle that you'll see as you go through
yeah I started to read I have a bunch of
books you guys are welcome to borrow one
at a time if you're sure you're taking
the class and you're sure you'll bring
it back so Elizabeth Colbert is very
very vocal about the politics and the
horrors of you know the sixth extinction
that we're in the middle of the second
third of this book the global warming
reader is all about the politics so i'll
probably be learning along with you
about that because so far would I know
about the politics is it's hard and it's
hard for a number of reasons but it's
hard but I do see hope you know those
news snippets that I was showing you
more people paying attention to it is
anybody in here actually a political
expert or policy person whoa where I
could it be done my foreground pull out
Wow
small island state mmm we should talk oh
but that's injured but rising sea levels
is a horror for the fit right Wow and so
what advice do you have to offer us here
our expert team comes later than I well
I'll take it's too much it's coming from
from kilometers small island states over
you in the summer oh okay these are the
those are the locations where I guess
the most outrageous or the most extreme
examples of ingenuity and including
engineering ingenuity and other with a
perspective of strategies to combat like
climate change and adaptation strategies
those thoughts thought the location
where those strategies are taking place
because it's like houses I hate the
paint in these terms but it's life or
death well it is like wow so they're
taking more extreme measures but this
type of technology might know it's not
applicable to do each other small
islands stations for talking tropical
locations here but those are the
politicians that are more amenable to
the point strategies like this yeah
there's different there's different
challenges there as well but when you're
looking we are looking to sort of trying
to find the business where these three
for these pincers steps are being made
progress is being made in the positive
direction you look to the
there could be most directly than person
affected by climate change allows this
progress by working from ruthless Mouse
or not I hope your shine your list that
are really taking a course are you i am
yeah okay great wow that's that's a nice
perspective anybody else have a policy
inside or connection that we should be
sure you participate every single class
give some advice here this is good cop a
lot of the stuff is is really important
we're talking abut the halls been
working for her group almost a year now
and it's ramping up to the conference
some people are are optimistic about it
she is left that my ambassadors less so
for different reasons those i can give
you some perspective well good at least
two minutes here or you can be more
prepared so next oh that's great thank
you thank you wow that is one thing i
love about this class yes if you
encountered any unexpected environmental
consequences of
um so if we did we'd pay attention right
we have found that one kind of material
that we've been using we found this
again in our little pools test recently
has this tendency to just migrate to the
side no matter what you do and it's
something it's one of the things that we
deployed in Minnesota but we didn't
notice it during the season in Minnesota
because we deployed while things were
frozen and when we do plan so at the end
of the season you know this mysterious
thing we couldn't find where where it
had got anymore I mean we could find
this but a different material it wasn't
quite as bright we just couldn't find it
afterwards what's intriguing but you
know it's fundamentally sands oh okay
it's not going to do anything in a pool
what a little wading pool in a parking
lot you know a bunch of them with
identical conditions you know just
testing cooling what we were finding was
that they would under rut within rather
short order find themselves clinging to
the side it's like you've got this vast
open space in the middle and it's all
clustered to the side it was the same
stuff that had disappeared in Minnesota
after the melt it was like oh but you
know is that an environmental
consequence no but it's it it says
that's not one of our first choice
materials because it's not going to do
much good for at least after the melt oh
yeah that's the point of having chosen
this family is it's hard to see what
it's going to do unless and this here's
the thing we need much more info on is
there a size range and you can get a
variety of size ranges of these is there
a size range where it's going to get
ingested by somebody and is that harmful
it may not be creatures some creatures
intentionally eat sand or small rocks
you know and so if it passes right on
through you might be okay or it might be
that in your particular ecosystem you
might want to you know compound things
to have them bigger or you might want to
intentionally use teeny so that's the
kind of things I think are going to get
the complex on the spot considerations
we're going to need yes
you get on top for leisure would you see
us on Marshall like taking it back those
pencil and water ball water following
morning on top pleasure oh there were
years past when I was really in this
tragic picture myself just taking a
suitcase full and then spending
undoubtedly the rest of my life in jail
but I was trying to do a good thing oh
so I haven't done that I did not fall
prey to that temptation but that isn't
you're bringing a very important point
it would you would probably think given
the way that I'm thinking that I would
want to spread this all over the Arctic
and that's not the right thing the thing
is to find the the essential spots and
so some of the spots that I think might
really benefit polar bear breeding
ground Hudson Bay is the main polar bear
breeding ground in the world that Fram
Strait where we saw all that ice
disappearing in the 30-something second
video of doom might be a really tempting
place to put some of this to try to be a
fluidic constrictor basically but to put
it everywhere would be insane and
remember you're going to have to allow
for shipping lanes because people have
gotten very excited that there could be
shipping lanes and I'm not going to
fight that you know it's like okay but
let us save enough to slow down the you
know the planetary warming problem I saw
it on your hand how are you can you make
sure that its face in the right spot and
if it's float away how can you like okay
great my good questions kind of stuff
yeah so when are we like optimizing yes
when you're testing in a small contained
body of water no issue but if you were
out on the open ocean Oh heaven so are
you going to figure it out right I mean
here when it's frozen you can easily
fence it but after the melt where does
it go and so if you're concerned about
that and if you're thinking that it's
going to melt every season if you're in
a place where it's going to do that then
you do have a couple choices you can say
well it's going to roam free and it's
going to do good somewhere else or are
you gonna write you up it's almost like
raising children Oh
go for it few good things or or you can
engineer it to sink after a season right
and so you choose the fragile one not
the one that you can run a truck over
those are really important questions
they are really important questions from
the ocean so maybe but if it's sand
right and if you're fundamentally trying
to work in I mean that's an important
point is we're trying to put a small and
material load as possible to do the most
good so we're talking about a mono layer
and so that's you know tens of microns
hundreds of microns thick it's not much
material and so that's the other thing
that keeps that that's why our economics
are better than big four inch black
plastic balls for instance right we're
trying to do more with with less and so
it seems like a minimal impact certainly
compared to the loss of the ice which
has been a major impact so but these are
these are great questions these are the
kinds of things that yeah we have to
worry about and have been worrying about
for a long time